- well hello there
thanks for joining us today we're back
on this blessed beautiful Friday
afternoon in America and evening in
Europe either way thank you for taking
the time to join us here today thank you
to our sponsors honey
expressvpn the undies and stitch fix I'm
happy to announce that on Friday to
Fridays from now the 30th of November
the great bill works will be here with
us which I'm so excited about so if you
want to leave questions for him on the
subreddit there's a thread up there
slash a trace reproductions been a wild
week for us here California and
California has been getting slammed yeah
this week I'm sure you all heard there
was a insane wildfire here in LA and
Ventura County and starting with a
shooting that we almost didn't even get
to pay attention to because there's like
the new cycles like it's just tragedy
sad sad stuff so yeah right around the
corner from my parents house there was a
shooting in Thousand Oaks and then the
net the next night after the frickin
whole town's on fire from a loved her
you know I read something I heard
something and correct me if I'm wrong
Dan but pretty sure this is true i fact
I did fact check it myself
there was one or two people that was in
that shooting and Thousand Oaks that was
also in the Vegas shooting being like
it's like dude what I mean whoa that's
that's a mind melt for that person but I
do want to say yeah my parents were
evacuated from their house they were
staying with us we were luckily not that
close to the fire but it was smoky and
there was ash everywhere it was really
scary the whole the main freeway in LA
the 101 was shut down yeah I mean it was
it was apocalyptic out here it was wild
we just had the news on like the whole
weekend yeah I'm gonna couldn't believe
it because it was a way it's like just
everything's on fire yeah and you don't
know if it's it could spread over to
where we
and just if the wind changes and goes to
the wrong direction you know but we are
looking at a place for my parents just a
week ago in Thousand Oaks or was
Westlake Village yeah and just a week
ago as this really beautiful little
community the gated community and it's
in the woods kind of and Thousand Oaks
is like a nature preserve so a lot of
the decks and they have trees coming out
of the decks and all the trees are
marked and it's like a protected area
but I remember being like man this is
pretty like I feel like a fire would
ravage this place pretty easily I was
telling my parents and that was a week
ago that whole place burned down yeah
the whole plate that whole community
burned down it's crazy stuff and just
there's been a real tragic loss of life
and property and I will talk about that
more later because there's a lot of
amazing footage and stories that came
out of that that I think's interesting
and crazy wild stuff dude
but before we get now as you guys can
tell from the title we have got to
address a lot of the criticism that
people have been saying against me a lot
of people are tuning in probably to
enjoy an epic meltdown for me to watch
me make a fool of myself so that's why
I'm here yeah dan doesn't usually I
sleep through the episode so I promise
we will get to that it's gonna be
fireworks guys it's gonna be explosive
but before we get to that I do want to
do a goof of the day to kind of lighten
it up a little bit here with this vape
god Tommy the vape God somehow this epic
troll got on fox news too
I guess he's speaking on behalf of the
how do you call those Dan the jewels
yeah which was these tiny little vape
pen it's like a pocket vape pen that
apparently like a middle school in high
school everybody's hitting these
which is so crazy to me yeah because
when I was a kid
smoking was already not cool there was a
couple of people that like went out in
high school to smoke a cigarette but now
all the sudden with vaping it's like
cool again and these kids are hitting
these jewels that like 16 years old so
this this guy got on the news and it's
just an incredible situation
specifically with regard to flavored
varietals that have helped propel the
explosion of these among the young here
now to folks on very separate sides of
this issue at barstool sports who
affectionately goes by the name Tommy
smokes first thing I'm going to try SiC
a drool trick yeah that guy ribs that
they think I think that Fox News always
does this where they'll bring like I was
watching this video during the Kavanagh
that whole thing they brought on a guy
who says he's an actual witch that does
incantations against him and he's like
the most absurd looking person you can
imagine it's like they always bring on
these people that you can't tell if
they're serious or not we're sure like
the perfect punching band to their so
this guy's apparently I think she's
taking him seriously which is well no
song Joel Kenny he's trying to pull out
these flavor to e-cigs shouldn't be
regulated even when teens are using them
and these increasing numbers well look
i'm 22 years old so i'm using them
legally and honestly they're just cool
like they're cool you rip them there's
nothing cooler than blowing a fat cloud
like right that's true the colossus I
just it helps my swag it helps my drip I
just love walking around it's really
good for getting chicks too so honestly
I started about a year ago and it does
help get you I know that for a fact
back since I have a question it's that
you use your cell phone quite a bit yeah
quite a bit okay so why don't you rig it
up to your phone and that way you won't
have like the actual calories burned by
grabbing your phone so you can Vicki
completely a lot Wow and kind of check
email and text at the same time you
don't like right off the side okay you
could that'll be your invention I'm
giving it to ya I'd vape like this yeah
keep switching devices you write that
did she pre-planned that gag or what
like I'm throwing the troll she's like
yeah the whole writing team came
together and we decided you should vape
out of your phone well I don't know if
this goes anywhere but I just wanted to
give a shout out to Tommy smokes the
vape god what a legend yeah you know he
went out there on Fox News into the
Lions Den and he and he fought the good
fight he held his own yeah you know and
for those of you wondering does vaping
help you get chicks yes
you didn't truly love me until I start
blowing flat clouds in her face so shout
out to Tommy now let's get to the reason
we are all here today I've been thinking
a lot about this let me take a little
sip of water here yeah this is difficult
for me to talk about because it's
something I've been thinking a lot about
of late I trying to wrap my head around
it and think about it you know honestly
and critically and trying to deal with
things and a healthier more mature way
and it's kind of I have a long-winded
kind of story here that I hope that will
be interesting and maybe helpful for
some people and maybe help some people
explain understand where I've been
coming from there's been a lot of
criticism of me of late there's been a
lot of people that have said lots of
lots and lots of videos and
[Music]
I have a natural aversion to criticism
specifically which is something that
I've been learning about myself through
therapy which I've started recently and
so they were out my career I've let me
start from the top I'm getting ahead of
myself what have people been saying
about me recently okay that I'm a
hypocrite that I prioritize money over
everything else that I've thrown friends
under the bus that I'm ignorant and
poorly informed and spread
misinformation that I'm arrogant that I
cannot handle criticism and that I've
used people just to name a couple of the
reoccurring themes I'm sure there's so
much more you could say about me and let
me just say this okay for the record
that I am guilty of all of those things
and I'm not gonna quantify it or make
excuses or anything I've done those
things I am I'm guilty of those things
and this is something that I've been
aware of myself over the past couple
last two years or so is that I have been
kind of slipping into a very unhealthy
place mentally and I want to try to go
through this and and make a sense of it
okay so it's been kind of a slow moving
process like it's been like a
self-fulfilling process in a way where
it's gotten worse and worse and I got
criticized more and more and I get more
defensive a more hold up and I went and
you know early on in our YouTube career
I went very early on to somebody that
was like universally liked I remember in
like 2016 I could do no wrong on YouTube
mm-hmm and like on reddit everybody
loved us we were voted like reddit you
know or reddit YouTube channel of the
year something in 2016 and like the
concept of being criticized on that
level was something I hadn't dealt with
and I think the problem was that I
people had me very high on a pedestal
back then
I mean people thought very highly of me
and there's no doubt that at the time it
definitely started to go to my head as
well and I'm pretty sure you know
looking back that I started to become
more arrogant and overconfident and on
some probably deep an unconscious level
a feeling of almost infallibility that I
could take anything on that when I had I
had like this and I really did I mean
it's hard to come to terms with that and
to confront that because at the time you
never rationally be like oh I'm out of
control I need to tone it down right and
so because of this combination of like
overconfidence and feeling like I could
take everything on it led me to make a
lot of mistakes and then when I was
criticized for those mistakes then I
would act extremely defensive and nasty
and not really processing them in a
healthy way like for example the leafy
thing was and the Wall Street Journal
thing and stuff like this where I kind
of just handled things in a really
overconfidence really thinking that I
can take on the world and not and not do
wrong and when I end up [ __ ] up it
finds out it comes out then when I get
criticized I completely shut down I
really I have that I psyche I'm learning
now through therapy which I've just
started doing about I've only been doing
for like a month or two but I have a
psychological problem where when I went
for for whatever reason that I don't
want to get into but the way I was
raised is that when I'm when I'm
criticized I psychologically shut down
and so before I became like famous on
the Internet
I had a problem with criticism but it
was so much less amplified but kind of
like when you become famous whatever for
lack of a better word it amplifies
certain aspects of yourself and it
definitely puts you through a gauntlet
of sorts of kind of
learning about yourself on an emotional
level and brings out all your flaws
amplifies everything and so that thing
of not being up behind of criticism in
my personal life was something that I
could get by on my life and not really
have any problems but then when you have
like hoards of people on the internet
criticizing you it can get so
overwhelming that it actually can cause
for me like a real psychological
shutdown which what I mean by that is
like I just feel it feels to me so
powerful like it feels like somebody
died like I get so emotionally and so
well the result of that one is like
extreme lethargy like I'll just lay down
on the carpet with like no well and then
the other thing is that like obviously I
get super defensive and super irritable
and super aggressive towards those that
criticize me in a way that's not healthy
and and instead of learning from
criticism deflecting it all the time and
making it the world's problem in online
right so that's kind of where my head
was
after these first blunders I made from
overconfidence I would say and did you
know things that I regret and it
shattered my ego in a way in a real
fundamental way that I've also learned
about myself as that I'm in my again
this is through pet therapy that's been
really helpful for me is that I'm in my
best most creative place when I have
that confidence and that kind of not not
a place of overconfidence or arrogance
but just feeling like that people like
what I'm doing that I like what I'm
doing that it should be a wholesome
great thing as an F and I so I think
that's one of the root problems why I've
had so much trouble creating videos for
such a long time is because I've kind of
lost my footing I've lost that wholesome
place and so everything became very
difficult for me having shattered my ego
and never
address that or deal with it or
confronted it and so what happened from
that is that a chain it's set off a
chain event of of defensive behavior and
caused me to be depressed so I want to
make clear that I'm not using depression
as an excuse for acting shitty it's
actually the opposite
I was not processing and handling
criticism I was losing my confidence my
ego was shattered and therefore it could
have make videos and all this other
stuff and that's what caused the
depression and so what happened now is
that the depression actually made
everything even worse right it made it
even harder for me so it got worse and
worse I get criticized more and more I
get more and more defensive and closed
up and I want to make clear you know I
just kept shoving it all deep down and
becoming more and more depressed
essentially and it's only been recently
that I've been I've kind of hit rock
bottom a couple months ago where I was
so amped up I was so so the depression
it amplifies all my negative feelings
right that's kind of what the problem
was and and and worst of all it made me
extremely irritable which is I don't
know if you know like irritable on that
on that level but it's the worst it's
the worst because not only do you piss
people off but you start to hate
yourself to him because you're you know
you're acting irrationally but the
emotion is so strong that it's like you
can't be ignored like just with ela for
example at home like a lot of times when
I would get aggravated or upset I would
direct my frustration towards you even
though had nothing to do with you
because I'm so irritable and I'm up to
and in that moment I know that it's
[ __ ] up and I'm being an [ __ ] and I
hate myself so much for it and I see
that it's upsetting you and then you get
angry at me but it's like it's just this
overwhelming
irrational and I've even learned you
recognize it and I would know that it's
almost like you're not being yourself
right now yeah but it's such a cycle
that I can I still I can't not get upset
because you're worse dude you were being
crazy so I have every right to be upset
we know that and then it's just such a
cycle like I can't get out of it yeah so
because of this crazy irritability I was
really just making everything more
amplified I was reacting way too
strongly and way too negatively to
almost everything even the slightest
annoyance I would lash out at things and
people that were completely blameless
super moody irritable guilty always in
my head about something and even a
negative comment or somebody even
criticizing me in the slightly slightest
would like sent me off and I would just
shut down even people that like respect
fleet would disagree with me mm-hmm what
turned me like bitterly against them so
I'm so bad right I was feel like I was
being attacked like fit like is like I
said it feels like somebody's dying feel
like I'm physically being attacked
almost like a flight or fight or flight
so for the longest time being stuck in
my head and not being able so the first
two years I've always felt like I'm not
being able to grown or learn or maturing
which is so difficult because I have
felt so stuck and like this really dark
black hole of negative feelings just
such an awful place and being so
frustrated I'm like why am I stuck here
how do I get out of here what do I do
about this I'm growing more and more
desperate you know by the week and just
falling deeper into that black hole and
so I would say about a month or two or
about two three months ago there's when
I kind of hit rock bottom and I was like
it was so I was just so miserable that I
was so tired of being myself that I was
willing to do anything to be anything I
want
I didn't no longer wanted to be myself
because I I was
prescribed antidepressants a long time
ago
and all throughout my life doctors have
been trying to get me to take them but
I've always not wanted to take them and
I think the reason for that is was
probably that well one of the reasons
was that I always felt like I wasn't
hadn't done enough to fix myself mm-hmm
like I kind of had this unreasonable
expectation that I should be exercising
two hours every day and eating salad for
every meal and that somehow was gonna
cure my depression and until I had done
that then I had no right to take
antidepressants mm-hmm but I think
another aspect was that I felt that it
was weak or that it was a change that it
would that I was weak or that it was
somehow giving up or that it was it
would change me I was afraid I'm not a
big drug user because I don't like
altering my state of mind and I don't
like becoming reliant on drugs but I was
afraid that it would change me and I
think at that rock bottom moment I felt
so strongly that you know what if it
changes me good because I don't want to
be this person anymore
whatever I remember hearing I don't know
why I was thinking about this quote from
Paul McCartney and John Lennon talked
about acid use and Paul said he never
really loved it because he was afraid of
it changing him but John loved it so
much because he wanted it to change him
and I will always thought how what an
interesting perspective and I feel like
I felt both of their perspectives now
you know my whole life I was like I
don't I'm scared to change and that and
then from going from that like I'll do
anything to change I'm praying that it
changes me so I had this bottle of
antidepressants in my bedside and I said
you know after dealing with this hitting
rock bottom I just I started taking it
I just I had nothing to lose and I
couldn't really go on anymore like that
and so you know I was I'll say this the
antidepressant is not at all what I
thought it would be the first two to
three weeks was a little rough I think
as your body adjusts to the medicine
because there was kind of well first of
all I was in such a bad place mentally
was kind of hard to tell mm-hmm
what was going on in my mind and what I
was feeling but it definitely made me
feel kind of like foggy and loopy and
zoned out it's really zoned out like
sometimes I would just be like just not
just totally absent like a member once
in the driving a lot of rails yeah we
were driving and like there's someone
crossing the street well I was driving
super slow and he was walking slow
watching my car so what yeah I was never
gonna hit him because he saw me coming
but like he was standing there waiting
for me to stop for him
and I was staring right at him but I was
just inching forward and I just he looks
like are you gonna stop and I was like
what he thought and I just I didn't see
him I was just so like so I almost I
actually almost gave up on the heads
headed president there was a but then I
would say around like three or four
weeks cuz everybody says it can be rough
in the beginning and then it starts to
work after like three or four weeks in
the side effects go away I had a lot of
anxiety too about being able to perform
being able to come out in the podcast
for make videos and feel like I'm myself
mm-hmm and after I kind of proved to
myself that I was capable of that that
he's a lot of my anxiety about taking it
too but what I noticed about the anti
depressant after all the side effects
went away and the fogginess and all this
annoying stuff is that I was it's kind
it's kind of crazy but I was not
irritable anymore yeah I was still
depressed I was still anxious I was
still misery
but what it did for me that has been so
amazing and I'm so thankful for is that
it first of all removed the this
irrational irritability and kind of gave
me the foundation and the tools to start
seeing things more for what they are and
not this kind of crazy irrational
irritable madness that I was
experiencing the world through and so
that for me was the first huge
breakthrough I had and dealing with my
situation and I would just notice it in
things mostly at home with ela and stuff
things that would usually cause somehow
a fight for no reason all of a sudden we
were like oh we did this without
fighting what didn't even get a little
and what happened yeah almost remove my
irritability completely and I'm telling
you this was like a godsend
I mean life-changing really
life-changing and it hasn't changed
anything else I'm come I'm completely
the same yeah I'm just less irritable
and it's just it's amazing what I
learned about antidepressants that it
just all it does is blocks your
serotonin receivers so they're as I
understand it I could be wrong about
this but it's called a serotonin uptake
inhibitor and so your body produces
serotonin which regulate your mood and
your happiness and contentment and stuff
like that and so this drug blocks the
receptor that absorbs the serotonin so
it makes more serotonin available for
your brain tumors so so so it just makes
you a little more you're it's it makes
your moods a little better
really I'm again for me it didn't change
me at all except that my irritability
completely went away and so things that
were making me crazy before I was able
to see it for what I was which I can't I
can't it's really little things like
it's just irrational so all of a sudden
you see it is like oh it's just a little
thing
it's nothing
you know we're before you it would say
you often do like room a day
yeah ruin your day or we would get in a
fight and then it would ruin and then I
would feel bad about making about
snapping at you yeah and it was but like
what how was it for you when I started
like yeah I noticed it immediately all
of a sudden like I it's almost like we
switched off sign I seemed irritable
compared to you I know I know I'm like
I'm not an irritable person I think oh
you're not you've always been like super
sane and grounded and great and III
wouldn't notice situations where I was
like it's always like we switch you a
little bit because I would be like oh
come on something would upset me and
you're like yeah that's fine yeah so but
you're in yeah definitely but you're the
same person yeah so that was the first
really important step for me because I
could now see things clearer I could
analyze things clearer and boy what a
difference I mean my goodness there's so
much stigma against antidepressants and
I really truly and I and I was I'm
guilty of that me too I thought if you
don't have to I don't even know why well
there's like your you feel almost like a
loser like you're weak like you failed
to solve your own issues yeah now before
we started doing YouTube and stuff I
wasn't that irritable right no
so was it kind of made me feel more like
how I used to remember being in a sense
that I I always prided myself on being a
more calm rational rational rational
person and that kind of the self-image I
had kind of melted away and replaced me
with this really grumpy mm-hmm obnoxious
person that I was starting to hate so
that that was huge I mean that that's
huge and I'm still on it and I'm so
happy that I'm taking it I remember in
college once there was I was having
awful anxiety you guys might know I had
like generalized anxiety disorder
I could have benefited so much from
antidepressant the college and I
remember there was a sign at my very
progressive school UCSC
it said something like it had like
prozac and it was like prozac nation
making some artsy claim that like oh
we're all over medicated and we're all
on Prozac and the undertone being like
you don't need this you're weak you're
sucker if you take it and I've never
seen that being like yeah that's
interesting
who needs that [ __ ] and that was a very
popular sentiment hmm I would say very
it's kind of like an anti-corporate like
anti like we don't need your medicine
also I'm a person that's very like I
said I have I have an ego problem and so
admitting to myself that I am weak and
that I need the help of a medicine for
me was difficult to was divil to accept
because it's in a sense felt like weak a
weakness that can handle it myself
mm-hmm the truth is about that that I've
learned is that looking reaching out for
help outside yourself is the first and
the most important step in recovering
from a situation like this because it's
not weakness it's it's truly a strength
because you have to get over your own
ego and you have to accept the Grace and
the help of other people and the tools I
mean this is a well-researched funded
backed by incredible intelligent
researchers and doctors and
psychiatrists and to just write that off
because you it's like I mean that's
that's stupid that's not strength that's
dumb all right so that was one aspect
and now the antidepressants are helping
but I'm obviously still depressed and I
am still you know not cured by any means
excuse me
so what was the next really important
step is that I was recommended a
therapist from a friend that I've been
doing for about like probably about a
month or two months a month and a half
and the therapy has been I've always
been skeptical about therapy too I think
probably for the wrong reasons cuz it
feels like week to say to another person
I need help
mm-hm you know but again it's like to
think that you cannot you cannot it's so
hard to understand what's going on in
your own mind like again therapists this
my doctor is a PhD I mean this guy has
learned studied schooled this guy knows
how the mind works and he's trained to
diagnose it and to almost debug it he's
probably seen so many people and so many
partners yeah
put together something from what you're
describing that you would never yeah see
yeah but the thing that like stuff from
like my childhood the way I was raised
and the way that I reacted things
there's psychological explanations that
are so important to explore so that you
can deepen your understanding of not
only yourself but the world it gives you
this incredible empathy for how other
people's minds work and how they're
affected by their environment and as I
touched on earlier there is a very good
psychological explanation for why I get
so defensive and shut down from
criticism that I don't want to really
need to get into it just goes back to
the way I was raised but just learning
about that and knowing about that and
talking about it is so therapeutic and
it's so important that it's given me a
such a good vantage point it's given me
kind of the tools and a little more
support and foundation to talk to even
come here and talk to you guys about
this like this now and to think about it
more of a healthy way and
- the last time I came in here and
addressed Chris on the podcast I was
ranting and raving and going looking
like a freaking lunatic and that's just
the symptom of everything that I was
describing and so for me being able to
come here and talk about this with you
guys I think is important for me because
I see the podcast as if nothing else
honest you know like when I sit here for
two hours live unedited over the course
of nearly 100 episodes now 100 hundreds
of hours of footage of me unedited it's
nothing else but at least honest right
because I cannot hide Who I am I cannot
hide my defects cannot hide my stupid
comments I cannot hide my short temper
my douchiness my shitty hosting you know
if I if I recorded this and put it into
a video I would cut all that [ __ ] out
yeah or like you you'll try a joke and
then we're like well that didn't come
off right so let's do it again but here
you don't even and you can't know and to
be honest with you it's this podcast has
been one of the most difficult things
I've ever done in my life like
physically if you talk about it from the
standpoint of just sitting and doing it
it looks like it's easy to do just sit
here you show up you talk and you you
know yeah but from a psychological from
a mental from a from a lot of other
positions is the hardest thing I've ever
had to do because one there's no
take-backs
and so not only are you the fans forced
to see me more clearly of Who I am but I
am forced to see more clearly of Who I
am because and I'm someone that's
criticized youtubers and people on
YouTube you know what you see it's very
people it's very nice when you post
videos and you can manicure it and put
it out and you put it out for the
people to see you one way and you get to
see yourself one way too because you cut
out the stupid [ __ ] and you forget about
it then people see the video and they're
like this good this guy's great
and you're like yeah I am great and you
forget about me well you're kind of a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
though your new hour of you being an
[ __ ] and then 10 minutes of you being
good exactly and so I'm not surprised
that so many people have watched his
podcast Hindman like whoa that's not the
guy I thought he was or people who were
making videos about like all the things
I mentioned because yeah it's it is all
in here everything you guys have said
bad about me and that you've noticed the
oh my bad personality traits and all
that it is it's all in here
you know I can't lie about that stuff
it's all here so it's been difficult
especially with this condition I've had
of being like depressed and irritable
and having a psychological leak
unhealthy response to criticism but it's
all played out here and it's kind of the
only way to do the podcast like our
first five episodes maybe we were trying
to edit down the footage and thinking
about it like we used to think about it
video but it just wasn't right like
you're cutting down a conversation and
then you're making decisions on what to
leave and it's not natural
exactly we came to that conclusion that
it has to be like this that's that's
right is it a podcast needs to be honest
it needs to be uncut because you've got
to see the essence in the soul of what's
there yeah a lot of times like you were
saying you know we would try to cut out
a part of me saying something stupid or
not just me but the gas start we were
like oh this is a boring moment let's
just go you know and that's just I think
a lot of people were feeling it we were
feeling it that it's like this isn't
weird yeah and so we took this leap into
doing it live and it's been really tough
and really challenging and very exposing
of me I'm here bare naked in a way
but I also think it's been really
amazing for me too because it's kind of
brought me here now where I've been able
to just take finally a close look at
myself mm-hmm and see it for see it more
clearly in a way that I've craved so
much these past two years to just feel
like I'm maturing and I'm growing and
I'm becoming a better more wholesome
person yeah and I'm just stuck I'm just
like why am I so [ __ ] stuck drive me
crazy yeah you would say that to me I
want to stop like just feel like I'm
stuck or how or where but just feeling
like I'm just pinned to the floor or you
know in a wig and a hamster wheel but I
think it's been it's been an amazing
experience in that way that we've all
we've all been just you know here here
it is I said those things I did those
things I am that person and it's good
it's good to acknowledge that and feel
that and be like you know it's good you
got it you got to accept that can't just
walk blindly and I mean it's just so
messed up dude like I said it's just a
black hole and it's not it's just what I
didn't understand it's just it's
strength it's not weakness to come
before yourself and confront your many
shortcomings as a human being mm-hmm
instead of ignoring them and I think I
was just I couldn't it was too painful
for me so it was my ego was hurt and I
was it's just too painful for me
it's so weird the psychology of it is so
weird you know you think it'd be so easy
to just be like yeah you're right you
know I [ __ ] up but it can be so
painful as Elton John famously said
sorry seems to be the hardest word yeah
I don't know why so it can be so hard
maybe not for other people but again
this is my specific problem I think that
I'm not learning about myself and I said
to ela something recently I'm still
depressed but for the first time in such
a long time I feel like there's a light
at the end of the tunnel mm-hmm which
for me it was this black hole there was
a no escape there was no answer all I
could think of was just permanent
darkness and now I subtle name with the
help of friends with the help of therapy
with the help of antidepressants with
the help of ela who's been with me this
whole time
there's just finally I can kind of see a
path forward to getting better a path to
walk towards the light you know and you
know with a kid on the way my god I
don't wanna be yeah I want to be better
than this right like that's gonna be
tough tough enough I don't need to make
it harder I you know
I want to say you know I readily admit
that I've been at times an awful host a
terrible interviewer here awful habits
as a podcast host you know speak on
things that I don't know nearly enough
about speak with certainty about things
that I shouldn't and I definitely need
to do better on these fronts I need to
be better I need to do better and I
expect myself when I want to be better
I've been you know I've heard someone
say I don't forget who said it but they
said if you're under a hundred podcasts
then you really have no idea what you're
doing
and I really hope that's true because
we're caught this is number 93 and I
know I still have so much to learn and
improve as a person as a host as an
entertainer mm-hmm as a human being and
we only have seven years oh and yet
despite all that so many of you have
continued to support us and show us love
and appreciation and to see the goodness
and the sweetness in me despite my best
efforts to thwart you at times I think
part of me was so I was so um I felt so
distance from the fans in a way recently
because on one hand there's people that
hate me
and so I'm like I'll [ __ ] them I don't
want to read the comic cuz I'm too
fragile and then the people that love me
I feel like because I hated myself and
didn't love myself that the love that
they will show me wasn't genuine that I
couldn't accept it mm-hmm it was just
them being nice or whatever I don't know
and so I think that yeah I just I don't
know I couldn't accept any of it it was
just too much for me but I do want to
say that from the most sincere and
appreciative place for the people that
have continued to believe in me and see
something good in me and something here
that you like that it is amazing and it
means so much to me and I wanted to
thank you all for your kind comments on
that
so before the Tom and Christina episode
I had made a side that nobody seemed to
like the podcast when there was a huge
outpouring of love and support in the
colonists telling me that I should keep
it up and that you guys loved it that
was unexpected and very much appreciated
and a time that I really needed to hear
that I have thought about quitting the
podcast honestly a lot yeah cuz it's
been such a pain you know
if it's such a pain it's been so painful
at times but I hope there's been good
things it's easy to focus on the pain
and to feel the pain to talk about the
pain I hope there's also you know
another side to it and if you do see
that side I thank you so much for
sticking with us and enclosing to this
long monologue which has gone quite a
bit longer than I expected I want to say
that if I have disappointed you I'm
sorry I know I can be better and I want
to be better to those that have
continued to support us and spend your
Friday your Blessed Friday's here with
us I want to say thank you for believing
in me and looking past my imperfections
and giving me the strength and support
to push through it and I do think that
it's important for me to talk about
these things because I think there's a
lot of people out there that can relate
to my feelings of this whole depressive
attitude and putting off getting help
because somehow for whatever reason in
your head I'm sure everyone has their
own reasons but that it makes you
vulnerable or weak or whatever it is but
I hope that people can take anything
from this that it's actually your
weakness and your vulnerability is part
of what makes you human and
acknowledging that and reaching out to
help is strength not weakness weakness
is shutting yourself up from the world
and then you can fix all your own
problems
mmm-hmm that's just bitter self-loathing
weakness and I hope that anyone out
there that is feeling I'm just you know
feeling anything similar what I said
that you do try antidepressants and
therapy there's a reason there's study
developed and used by millions of people
and professions this is a science this
is a discipline
these people are amazing and they're
here to help you yeah anyway I don't
know I hope that was interesting at
least I don't know if that's what you
all wanted to hear for me but that's it
what do you thank you anyway thank you
guys all for listening and bearing with
me through that so love you all and we
will be right back after this short
break
nobody wants to feel like they're
overpaying while shopping online
especially during this holiday season
gifts travels ugly sweaters it all adds
up but you know there's an easy way to
always get the lowest price it's called
honey my dudes honey's a free shopping
tool that automatically saves you money
while searching the internet for the
best promo codes when you shop online
that means that wherever you're shopping
you're getting the best deal without
even trying on your favorite sites like
Amazon eBay j.crew Walmart Sephora
Expedia and more so much more honey has
over 10 million members and each user
has saved on average passively without
even trying 28 dollars and 61 cents
they've got a hundred thousand five-star
reviews on Google Chrome store there is
no reason not to add honey to your
browser today because let me tell you
this it's free it works passively and
immediately all you do is go out the
checkout and it does a little it enters
the matrix and it's like boom here's
your coupon it's that easy my dudes try
it out you got nothing to lose get honey
for free at join honeycomb slash h3 join
honey calm slash h3 honey's the easiest
way to save money online while you shop
online with all the recent news about
online security breaches it's hard not
to worry where my freaking data goes
making an online purchase or simply
accessing my email could put my private
information at risk you're being tracked
online by social media sites marketing
companies and weird freaking pervs in
the bathroom of airports that are
stealing your credit card and your nude
pictures that's right if you're using
public Wi-Fi internet anywhere in a
motel hotel without VPN you are putting
your butthole shots at risk and I've
sent Elam many and trust me I don't want
anyone else seen those I cannot live
with that being leaked ok that's why I
decided to take my privacy back and
using Express bbm expressvpn has
easy-to-use apps that run seamlessly in
the background of my computer phone or
tablet turning expressvpn protection
only takes one click expressvpn secures
and anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP address protect yourself with
expressvpn and it cost less than
seven dollars a month that's a lot less
than it's gonna cost you to fix your
credit after somebody steals your stuff
okay and or the emotional damage of
strangers seen your butthole let's put
it that way
protect your online activity today and
find out how you can get three months
for free at expressvpn dot-com / a tree
that's expr e SS VPN comm / HD for three
months free with a one-year package
visit Express Express VPN com / h3 to
learn more this is the year you can
finally tackle your holiday shopping
early and guess what you get everything
you need for you and your loved ones at
me on DS that is right
mandis has the coveted micro modal
fabric that is three times softer than
cotton and if you've never felt this
fabric get ready to experience pure
bliss and underwear for now as you guys
know I've made famous how stretchy and
breathable this me undies micro modal is
okay now to spare you a shot of my
genitals I'll put a hand here but name a
fabric that you can drape over you like
a body bag and still be in perfect
comfort and and breathability this stuff
is a game-changer okay they've got it
you got to try it they're really true
this is bliss okay now they've got
holiday prints they got new prints every
Tuesday that means you've got no excuse
not to celebrate the holidays right down
to your core and why stop at undies me
undies is launching holiday print in
lounge pants as you can see and onesies
as well both are made from the same
beautiful coveted micro modal fabric how
can you not get you and your loved ones
a matching pair of this breathable
beautiful me undies micro moto
so listen up first-time purchasers when
you get me undies you get 15% off and
free shipping
whoa Wesa no-brainer because you get 15%
off the most comfortable pair of undies
you will ever put on to get 50% off your
first pair of free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guaranteed that is a no
risk proposition go to my undies comm /h
3 that is me Indies comm /h 3
if you're like me and most guys hate
going to the store you hate shopping for
clothes you hate picking out clothes
I liked when I was a kid and my mom you
suggest me I'm not gonna lie it's so
much more convenient it's so much nicer
and let's face it she's got better taste
that's what stitch fix does for us guys
today okay they're an online personal
styling service that finds and delivers
clothes shoes accessories to fit your
body budget and lifestyle go to stitch
fix calm slash age three and you tell
them your size what style you like how
much you want to spend on each item and
you'll be prepared with your very own
personal stylist who will hand pick
items and send them right to your door
then you try them on pay only for what
you love and return the rest shipping
exchanges and returns are always free
there's no subscription required you can
sign up to receive scheduled shipments
or get your fix whenever you want stitch
fix styling fee is only 20 bucks which
is applied towards anything you keep
from your shipment and that's how we do
it guys going to the store know that you
don't got to do that okay all you got to
do is go to sushi fix calm slash h3
you'll get an extra 25% off when you
keep all the items in your box
that's stitch fix calm slash Aegis we
didn't get started today stitch fix calm
slash h3 give it a shot
thanks for watching and we are back you
know in the spirit of uplifting you all
this podcast and keeping spirits high I
will not talk about the fires
devastating this date until we've
watched a funny video first okay
now their deal do you want to watch a
wedding dress explode or my new favorite
show now on see TLC is the best network
on television every show is an absolute
golden nugget you know what we're ones
like you want a wedding dress a good so
90-day fiance as you guys know is my new
passion in life but I have to wait a
week dude I'm in so deep and that is
like there's a guy you know Larissa and
the other guy are in jail and I'm like
who are you talking about and there's
like 90 day fiancé
oh okay but it's fascinating right but
you're like talk about them like it's a
because it's it's so freaking amazing
and like there's this really vibrant
community on reddit of 90 day fiancé
they've got all these great memes and
discussions and it's fantastic
it's so good but I need something to
watch in the week between and so the new
show that I found is called extreme
cheapskates
now these people are cheap on a level
that is probably should be classified as
a mental illness because it's not like
getting what's on sale at Ralph's it's
not like getting these guys like there's
a guy and there they're like proud of it
too it's very interesting right they're
all like they're all they all have
significant others that are super
embarrassed by them which I find but
they yeah they seem exactly they all
seem to be in really healthy
relationships yeah but like for example
this is one guy he's like 40 and he's
retired he's like I have financial
freedom I'm retired from being a
cheapskate and none of my other friends
have this this freedom in life and this
guy spends his whole day biking around
for 12 hours not because he loves biking
but because gas is too expensive
checking phone machines for money going
to diners and checking the cushions for
coins mm-hmm and it's like that doesn't
sound like financial freedom that sounds
like you could just get a job and work
less hours but they have got like this
need to think it's it's this need to
feel like they got it they yeah they got
that one up and the result of some of
this stuff is absolutely bananas so this
is one of my favorite bags here
this guy's such a legend he's such a
legend that during the first season they
only had six episodes this guy was in
two of them by the way Amazon videos you
can decide to buy season HD or SD and I
went super in the
heard of this oh by the way what's going
on there we were gonna make a video and
it didn't work out and all this left is
a stupid [ __ ] Erica I love that the
video didn't work out well you're
keeping the haircut we had this whole
idea for video was gonna be so good and
I cut my hair for the reaction and all
these sketches and we're sitting down
editing it yesterday and I'm just like
we're both like this isn't good I just
cut my hair for nothing you know I'll
walk outside because I feel completely
normal and I'll forget that my hair
looks like this and I'll walk outside
without thinking a walk shredder
and you just you're just that guy I know
some days I look in the mirror like last
night and I'm like almost a kind of a
good luck yeah the way you'd kind of
have your head tilted to the camera that
that side looks okay but then yeah
that's a problem Mad Max fallout five
dollar coffee so you know wasn't been
interesting cuz I buzzed my whole head
and I took a frickin razor blade and
razor blade my scalp and that was gnarly
dude but it was actually kind of amazing
I have to say weird oh yeah it was
painful it was bad I have a new
appreciation for people that shave their
heads with razors but it was kind of
nice I think I'm gonna buzz it all off
and pick my whole freaking head it's
like it's such a freedom in a way
because your hair is gonna grow back all
beautiful and healthy mm-hmm and how
often do you get to see yourself just
like bald everyone at home is also like
[ __ ] you dude
every day every day it's not being bald
is not a meme
I'm appropriating bulbed culture um
where was I oh yes
extreme cheapskates let's see what we
have here so yeah I was saying this guy
I only had six episodes the first season
oh no what I was saying is that on
Amazon you can buy a season HD or you
can buy SD and save one dollar and you
have to dig they have a more options
button you have to go in there and in
the spirit of extreme cheapskate
I saved a dollar I was very proud in
honor of these guys most people consider
paper towels disposable like reuse them
up a little boost it up blah blah like
could we use these paper towels
three to five times Roy estimates that
over the last 10 years
he saved nearly $2,000 just by reusing
paper towels but doesn't that way dental
tasks we saving we hunted his toiletries
blades which are kind of flimsy on these
disposables they get dull I sharpen them
on the striking part of a book of
matches give him a whole new life you
can't squeeze any more else and it
appears to be empty that's the end and
they just toss it away
[Music]
and there's a week's worth still left in
there I buy cheap to play toilet paper
and I get two rolls out of one that I
have that I saw you need those two plies
buddy especially at your consumption
level we've seen what what he eats do
and do we have the clip of him at the
restaurant because I need that one no we
got to watch that one smart this is
nothing a little toilet plate there's a
lot like legs in general the closer you
get to the end the faster it seems to go
that's a pretty the funny thing about
that I've noticed about these chips
these uh cheapskates is that they spent
so much time it cannot be a worthy
investment of their time I guess they
don't work that's the thing but like the
guy will spend an hour D plying and then
re rolling a roll of toilet paper to
save like I don't know 25 cents or
something you know I'm it's like these
guys have but you got to see this guy at
the restaurant because that really is
ain't ain't nothing let's see here
extreme oh the movie day you've got this
one I can't believe brought me to the
movie so she's begging him this whole
episode to take her on a date night
which I guess they do once a month or is
it once a year once a month and so she
wants him just to buy him a soda pop in
some popcorn and he's like whoa come on
baby what are you crazy
so he has a novel idea that some of you
could use at home and in your zone
are you hungry yeah I've told you I
wanted something so much could I have a
banana it's a big waste of money to buy
food at the snack bar our concessions in
any movie theater yeah
keep it low yeah people smuggle food
into the movie theaters all the time I
don't like it but they do it by bringing
my own snacks I save at least another
$10 eating a banana at a movie there is
the saddest [ __ ] I can imagine like damn
banana and she's begging him the whole
time I want a coke and have popcorn you
said you didn't want the Apple
I don't want an apple I told you what I
wanted when I came in but I want to give
up corn candy or a drink sistent on that
alright yeah well I'm in a movie what is
even going on in that theater I think we
went to a crazy matinee yeah they went
to like the cheapest show in the state
or it's just completely empty you know
probably it's like 3 p.m. on a wait I
don't know Tuesday who knows but here we
go
my lucky day
popcorn
through the garbage she grabs a bag of
popcorn he's literally rummaging through
the garbage he does the decent free
refills with it popcorn and soft drinks
so I found a few containers in the trash
that surprised my loving wife
so by the way I liked he pocketed a
bunch of straws you know this lady after
being together for how long as they have
she knows not to ask questions she's
just like thank you you made it happen
let's not probe too deep here so at they
didn't show but at the end on the way
out he fills up the popcorn in the
Saline again the restaurant [ __ ] is
crazy he got I don't I couldn't find a
clip of it but what was the other family
that does it I saw this is important I
might be I might be he's like a
borderline freakin Regan ya know tell me
about friggin it freeganism is is people
that I I don't know if they exclusively
are always vegetarians or vegans but
they they have this philosophy that it's
okay to eat anything as long as it is
being thrown away so it's like a whole
diet based off of dumpster diving
essentially there was a guy like that in
the show yeah I think this guy's down
for anything as long as it's cheap so
this family is gonna last when I show
you guys but I urge you all to buy this
on SD and save that dollar hmm so this
guy their house was so wild so he takes
his family out once a year with change
he saves all year to treat them for
enduring
so he takes them to a buffet and this is
wonderful you can imagine the dismay on
everyone's faces son pulls up to a
Chinese buffet I couldn't believe it
all I can see was food stacked upon each
other we were modest fine dining near of
the table we at least agree to give it a
try
I guess we're here his wife's aunt
showed up at the last minute sting -
always helps him out I guess and they're
like oh cos on auntie's coming with us
and he was like the plates on ya I was
so mortified that he would even suggest
it so it oh it's so the guy we just wash
in this guy does the same thing so at
the end of the meal they start taking
out doggy bags and then everyone in the
restaurant who hasn't finished their
food they start hitting them up and
saying can I can I take this home yeah
that to me what's the best part of this
show and I don't know why and there's a
guy paid in coins too right yeah and
they don't show him pain
he whips out like a pantyhose full of
pennies it's so good maybe they started
that YouTube trend of like huh like
they're Bradbury's we're buying Gucci
store with pennies that guy's like dude
that's just my life what's the prank I
highly recommend this show is so
entertaining
there's so many more great clip these
clubs don't even do this show justice if
I'm being honest but enough about the
funny light-hearted stuff let's bring it
down yeah no actually I do want to talk
about the California fires because I
have a lot of incredible footage that I
want to show you guys
it's been so nuts out here like I want
to emphasize how was just one day all
good and then in that evening on the
news it was like the whole freaking
state was on fire yeah I heard a stat
that up north
that's the campfire right the agretti
this fire was spreading at the rate of
one football field a per I don't want to
say it wrong one football field per
second
what's really yeah that sounds well
maybe well well yeah I mean no it's just
hard to fathom it well it explains then
why up north especially there's 631
people missing that there's a good
chance there dad so because this fire
was moving so fast and so furious that
people were chilling in their home or in
the car in the mountains and didn't even
realize they were in an evacuation zone
and then all the sudden you see some
Amber's coming over the ridge and by the
time you're packed up in your car the
fires consumed the whole yeah I mean so
there's a town up north paradise
paradise
I do ironically named so this town yeah
I mean it's really beautiful in Foresti
but the state is so dry from a lack of
rainfall that basically everything's
just ready to go up which is what makes
these fires so severe the population was
27,000 and in this city nearly 12,000
homes and other structures were burned
down whoa 12,000 yeah it was at 6,000
like the whole city I mean like a whole
city was burned down 12,000 homes and
other structures and 631 people
unaccounted for seven people died in
their cars in Paradise the boys was so
hot that aluminum wheels melted it burnt
it burned
paradise up north a hundred and forty
two thousand acres I have no way to
fathom yeah what that means but I have
some videos I want to show of kind of
some occur all these people survived and
are unharmed and we we had the Woolsey
fire going on in our area and that one
seems crazy and then once we heard the
numbers of the one in the north it's
like oh my god it was way worse
destruction unbelievable I think here
because la is so densely populated the
evacuation here was way crazier there
was a hundred and seventy thousand
people who were under mandatory
evacuation there were six hundred
structures destroyed and three
fatalities in this fire and the one in
LA and Ventura County I want to show
some some footage again all the or more
well here that's that's what it was
according to the stats I have in front
of me correct me if I'm wrong then those
were I would pull that from CBS News and
they published it around noon today so
it's about as up-to-date let me see here
so this is the stuff is so it's like out
of a movie like I can't believe this
stuff okay yeah perfect right so this is
just where was this wrong god the this
is the Paradise campfire the one up
north so you can imagine like describe
it for the UH so it's a guy thank you
Dan for reminding me so this is a guy
driving down a road and I mean it's
Hellfire just Hellfire rate up in hell
fire on both sides amber when smoke and
it's the highway to hell man and this
fire was so like I said spread so fast
and so furiously cuz it was so windy
yeah the Santa Ana winds which is like
pressure from ha I don't know how the
science works but it gets really windy
and really dry and so this guy could
very well just be at home not knowing
anything's going
and then all of a sudden he's trying to
escape and here this is what it looks
like yeah you can only imagine how hot
it would be in that card yeah a lot of
people met their end when from that car
literally that's so horrible so this is
one look here the car can also just stop
at any moment because of the lack of
oxygen and those like turns off and you
get you're just wow stuck there yeah
that's well also trees could fall on the
road I mean yeah I never thought of lack
of oxygen oh that's crazy I don't know
which one oh I think this was from
Canaan this is right right in Woodland
Hills and we've drove up and down this
road a million times
so how's that frame up that's okay
yeah what's good she's driving what is
usually a really beautiful and scenic
road down to the beach down to Malibu
and it's just oh yeah so she's going
through a tunnel on the ground and as
she emerges on the other side you can
see the amber red glow start to emerge
she comes out of the tunnel and it's
just like that's such a scary drive to
do in such a time cuz it's like you
drive to a mountains there's already
it's not going back side - yeah
it's just smoke and fire amber actually
visibilities like one foot yeah you can
hear the you can hear the crackling how
the hell did she record this that blows
my mind that she was able to drive and
recalling the wheel you know and got our
fun I mean I'm in this ooh it looks like
she's out because she's in another
tunnel and she's coming out and then it
once again on the other side of the
tunnel it's just endless fire and ash
and smoke she opens the window you hear
that
that is divorce road to beyond and this
time it's a scary driver on a regular
day because it's so twist and turn and
mountains and I'm amazed that she was
able to record this yeah I mean how can
you there's so many far over yeah I
haven't watched 50 but yeah that's but
she makes me she's fine I saw interview
with her afterwards she's laughing about
the experience totally fine but I I
don't wish that experience on anyone I
mean that is so terrifying
um but my god she is a hero for I mean
imagine you're driving for your life and
holding a phone recording it on one hand
that's something she needs to be like a
professional camera lady or something
cuz she's got it she's got potential
yeah incredible stuff Kanan is a
landmark in in Los Angeles it's this
beautiful really beautiful Canyon Road
that goes down to Malibu beach so mm-hmm
it's weird to think of it from a
beautiful scenic route to that she's
like Hellfire Hell so there's more yet
well have we here I just thought this
was so crazy here you can see that the
freeway full of cars fire creeping up
the side of the cliff and then a
helicopter dumping water on the freeway
as cars are still on the freeway I mean
the fire spread so fast they didn't even
have time to shut down the freeway and
evacuate it so you can see these you'll
see it's unbelievable I mean that's
crazy
look at this helicopter is literally
dropping water on cars on the freeway
being in that car you just like alright
and the worst part is that people are
stopping to look so there's traffic
like stop and go traffic right next to
the fire why would you stop I think it
looks like you see this they're all
they're all right next to the fire just
stop and go traffic it's just cuz
there's down the merging oh that is so
so [ __ ] scary but that's just a
testament to how fast this thing spread
like look at this just on the freakin
freeway people got actually splashed
crazy huh
and I do want to say I was up at 5 a.m.
the night that it broke and these
firefighters are freaking amazing yeah
like being a firefighter in California
or well any firefighters are amazing I
have a lot of respect for firefighters
in general but these guys were grinding
it out 5 a.m. raging in front and
they're out there all dug 24 hours just
fighting this [ __ ] mm-hmm I had a
profound appreciation for them and there
was a lot of police involved in a lot of
I saw a clip of endued I know they say
you're supposed to evacuate and
everything but I saw a dude he had like
a looked like a pretty poor house and he
had like a farm and animals and [ __ ] and
his whole neighborhood I was watching
this live last night or not last night
when it was happening and his whole
neighborhood was engulfed in flames and
the students just there with the garden
hose is putting out Amber's and it
looked like he saved his house man I
mean he was just there with the freaking
garden hose like against this force of
nature so huge respect for these
freaking amazing people out there and
even now the fire is still going you
know I don't know it's still I could be
wrong Dan it's like what 60 contained or
something yes
one and then one close to us and yeah I
mean the one up north is still raging as
well so that's what you it's hard to
appreciate they're like now that kind of
the dust is settled in the city this
fire is still raging on and these guys
are still fighting it I just can't
imagine that moment you come back to
your house and it's gone
mm-hmm where do you start it's like I
just look at the woolsey fire that is 70
percent contained the one up north the
camp fire only 45 percent contain still
gosh she was many really luxurious huge
expensive houses burned down
yeah well a much like architecture and
art and why not I hadn't heard if if it
had been confirmed whether or not his
house survived but the director
Guillermo del Toro which you know I know
you're a huge fan of water but he has a
huge he has a huge private collection of
artwork from a lot of really famous
artists his house about when I heard
about all they're like I think it burned
I think I heard a burn did he that
that's me let me guess crazy because he
had he had a bunch of really awesome
pieces and I'd be wrong about that maybe
you guys can factor that I'm curious I'm
gonna look it up yeah I know that was
like as of day or two it this is only
minor smoke damage yeah a lot of
super-rich people which is good in a way
that because these are people that can
take it but on the other well they're
like their lives are not ruined but
right that's not to dismiss the pain and
suffering that they'll surely into her
yeah from losing all of their worldly
belongings and Konya oh yeah yeah kinda
hired private firefighters to watch his
house and protect his house which was
interesting god bless him
his neighbors - of evidently which which
does neighbors his neighbors were
thankful for him but it was his oh yeah
that's what I meant is that not just to
protect only yes but like to protect his
whole yeah I didn't know you could do
that but like private firefighters they
were saying his house is worth 60
million so I think when you have so much
to protect well you're saying you're
saying when other people's houses are
burning well it's just you know you
can't afford the private firefighters to
your house burns it's not really fair I
mean well world isn't fair and yeah army
of firefighters goddammit you go for it
pani don't save this whole neighborhood
probably help the firefighters a lot
because they don't have to come that's
true
[ __ ] waste resources on I guess my
thought is just out these private
firefighters nobody pays them do they
just stay at home like well I know
they're probably not necessarily
firefighters just like right it's
probably like ex-military kind of sure
you know yeah but I had the same I had
the same sounds weird yeah it's not it
does sound weird I'm trying not to be
cynical about it because my first
impression was like you know yeah
exactly what you write must be not but
on the other hand it's like you know
what if you got the money if you got the
if you got it flaunt it oh for sure
I don't blame Kanye for doing it hell
yeah but I bet you in the end it
probably did help the firefighters love
because they're not saving that yeah
right he's like start with my house but
then you know help other people if you
can you know I gotta say I don't like
talking about politics and I don't like
talking about Trump and I'm not a forest
ranger obviously so I don't know how to
analyze this statement the validity of
it but Trump's first response and and as
someone that lives here I want to read
this to you there is no reason for these
massive deadly and costly forest fires
and comfortable like oh thank you
there is no reason for is this better
much better there's no reason for the
massive deadly and costly forest fires
in California except that forest
management is so poor billions of
dollars are given each year with so many
lives lost all because of gross
mismanagement of the forest remedy now
or no more federal payments this was his
first statement he did end up saying a
lot of nice things and encouraging stuff
but you know again I'm not a park ranger
so I can't assess his statements all
that might be completely and perfectly
valid right up to that last sentence
where you suddenly threaten pulling
funding like you know have that fight
after we've stopped the fires maybe sure
yeah my problem was just like as someone
that lives here is like I don't know I
feel like the world needs a little more
tenderness you know a little more
compassion right now and especially in
these times when we're so divided and
everything's so political and I don't
know I just felt disappointed that our
president was making a political point
or using it to make a point or to attack
people when people's houses were still
burning good we're dying in fires yeah I
just like man I mean you you might be
right I'm not even gonna get into trying
to analyze who's right and who's wrong
but I just wish that there was more
freaking tenderness and compassion and
the planet for each other right I mean
if there may be a lot of validity to
what he's saying about mismanagement and
you know things that can prevent it but
when it's an ongoing disaster it's not
it's not over like people are still
dying it's like just you know next month
let's talk about that let's talk about
what we can do better
I don't know and Donald Trump really is
a role model for a lot of people a lot
of people look up to him and they've
Aaron and I just think I don't know it'd
be nice to see more compassion in the
world and less of whatever this is
that's all and so I thought it was
relevant just a little disappointed by a
fire leader I mean he leads all of us
not just his base he's still the
president of California even though
Californians hate
in general you know I definitely am
going to donate to support the people
that have been affected by this I was
trying to research the best place to do
it the mayor of Sacramento which is the
capital of California and just south of
this really incredible fire up north
straight from the horse's mouth is that
derogatory is that a relevant saying the
horse's mouth
it's very bigoted against horses mmm
straight from the mayor's mouth if you
want to help the victims please don't
send supplies as the evacuation centers
say they have been inundated those
working on the front mind say that
giving to the Red Cross or habitat.org
is the best way to help so these are
some good recommendations from someone
directly involved in this to give you
some ideas if you want to help I'm
definitely gonna donate myself so there
you go I've just feel awful for everyone
yeah it's just it's just you know this
promise thing going on a cow for these
wildfires are just so they've gotten so
out of control every season I was
watching a documentary on Netflix that
was really interesting about it about a
guy who's been following I forget the
name of it maybe you can look it up for
me one of you guys and better check it
out it's about a documentary crew that
follows firefighters over the course of
like a whole fire season hmm and the
firefighters are saying that in the past
like 10 15 years he's been getting
progressively worse and the seasons been
getting longer because there's the
change in weather and the change in
climate has produced less rain in
California and so everything's more dry
and it's just making the fires way worse
there's a lot of dead trees there's a
lot of dry trees and California's a ton
of wilderness
so it's incense from due to the change
in weather just a huge matchbox just a
huge so every season like this this one
now yeah fire chasers thank you Dan on
Netflix was really captivating watching
I watch it incredible footage last year
the one in Ventura was the worst in
history it was the most destructive in
California history and now this year the
one up north beat that record already
and it's still burning Ventura County I
don't know what's gonna this poor guys
man I'm from Ventura originally they're
just getting crushed man I feel so bad
for them two fires shooting they had
that shooting and the next night before
they can even mourn for the loss of like
11 lives I think was 12 la novia that
there that the freakin counties on fire
same people that needed to mourn had to
evacuate exactly man
rough probably if I had to guess a
result of all the gay people what bring
in the wrath of God no there's there's
like all these preachers that say all
the fires and everything bad happening
in the world is because of gay people I
swear to God the Westborough not just
Westboro I mean people like more
reputable than that like people with
actual yes I have to look into the
specifics of it because I don't want to
say anything not true but I've seen lots
of clips of preachers being like oh all
the fires out here in California is
because of the gays you know when you
rub tube dicks together what do you
expect to happen huh when you rub two
dicks together it causes more than just
semen to erupt it causes sparks it's
like two sticks two sticks rubbing
together God said no like I rubbed two
big sticks and a whole fire burned the
state down if that ain't the God gazed
and I don't know what it is here that's
why God says you
because if you rub dick dry you could
burn the house Oh
Ella's got there it was pastor Blaine
come here you go it was all over this
let's see
pastor blames Coughlin Wofford's on
states embrace me of LGBTQ reasonable
stance right there
now Trump says that it's because of the
poor forest management and the liberal
saves because of climate change but I I
have an alternate theory that it's the
gays when two men rub dicks together it
can cause more than just ejaculate known
for inflammatory claims passenger kevin
swanson got a little subtle upon their
inflammatory claims pastor kevin swanson
is drawing a link between california's
devastating wildfires and the state's
embrace of same-sex marriages well it
sounds foolproof yep remnants of god's
punishment of the Golden State for
legitimizing the sin of homosexuality
imagine being God in you hate gay people
that much the first gay God must be
really closeted or something because he
hates gays like way too much the first
gay pride march occurred in San
Francisco in 1970 and then San Francisco
legitimize homosexuality in 1972 he said
in 2005 California state legislators
became the first state in the nation to
pass the same-sex marriage law 2018 well
ok you gotta have to draw more
correlation than that what is a Jim
Baker's act when you guys find a video I
want to watch a video of one of these
guys sure now now a lot of people say
that climate change is making the state
dry but what I say is that it's dry
butthole that's causing the fires what I
say is that the gay people having way
too much fun
it's causing all these dang fires please
donate to my church because I need
another private jet what else we got
here folks we got um what the eff we got
men with beards are more attractive than
those who are clean-shaven really agree
really new study finds huh Dan have you
found that to be the case you seem
shocked yeah well you know as having a
beard not helps you there's there are
statistical outliers I guess well just
imagine how about how ruffed be if
you're shaving well that's true
that's a good point I mean have you gone
have you been beardless in the past and
uh to be honest very rarely like not
since I was a teenager basically I've
had a beard well I'll tell you I've had
a beard pretty much since I could and
I'll tell you that when I clean shave I
feel like a monster I feel yeah it's not
good you know also it really like if you
come to kiss me or something it feels
horrible to you don't when you see that
perfectly it becomes like sandpaper yeah
I hate it but the the thing I think the
real ticket for me well this guy's
handsome is [ __ ] with or without a beard
so I mean you know no guy like me like
here he is like but formerly they did a
study and they showed how much are you
like they want to [ __ ] this guy they
just showed people probably but I do
think in my case the beard it just hides
my face and I'm gonna be honest and it's
fine I'm not that insecure about how
ugly I am that is one thing I'm
comfortable with but if you criticize me
I'll shut down but I don't know if
that's what it is
it covers my face I don't I my details
are not that good I've got a tiny chin
I've got chubby
cheeks everything going on here is not
beautiful chiseled I don't look like
Superman over this ass that's the Fifty
Shades cover it as much as possible you
can see my nose my eyes my eyebrows
that's okay I don't know if that's what
it is but I agree with the you win to
stay with the premise of this do you
think I look better with a beard yeah
and you look looks for when I shave no I
think that about everybody no I think I
do think that it looks better not and I
don't like a longer beard though that
shirt no there's a point well that's
actually what the study found to write
that uh did they check about that well
let me let me there's there's there's
four tiers there's like clean-shaven a
little bit of stubble a decent amount of
stubble and then like a full beard and
the decent amount of stubble which I
think was ten days no shaving that was
let me read many what full beards are
seen as more attractive than men who
have just a light stubble according to
results of a new study they don't say
what this study is so I don't know if
it's reputable in any way but it makes
sense researchers found the widely
celebrated attractiveness of bearded
stars like Jaime Dorman Jake Gyllenhaal
and Chris Hemsworth is apparently no
coincidence doesn't hurt that they're
incredibly handsome as well exactly
mm-hmm the most beautiful men in the
world are found a tracker
although could that be a cultural
phenomenon because I feel like in the
50s having a beard was seen as kind of
like a beard that's kind of like a new
thing to come back i if I'm not mistaken
you know it definitely became like super
hipster throughout the long yeah
barren to buy like beard oils yeah let's
see as part of the experiment male
subjects were photographed clean-shaven
five days after shaving ten days and
then after a whole four weeks without
shaving 8500 women were asked to rate
the men on attractiveness as a long-term
romantic partner heavy stubble ten days
was found most attractive while fold
beards grown over four weeks came second
oh wow they like the fall even more than
the light stubble
like stubble was third while
clean-shaven was ranked Alise attractive
you know shaving is so annoying I hate
shaving to the skin on my face because
it air takes your skin and I feel like
that's part of why I don't like it too
because I know that it's it doesn't look
comfortable I'm like like you shave your
legs imagine denying your basement jeez
Louise
I'd like razoring like some parts like
my neck in the back I use a razor for
the back of my neck in the shower that's
changed my life mmm
but this is so the reason I grew a beard
to begin with is because it's so
irritable I keep getting like dried out
and oily is a whole goddamn thing ever I
know this weird question but have you
ever had a professional shave where they
use like a straight razor and like
somebody does it for you I don't know
that I have Dan it's so strange
no I'm kidding that wasn't that weird
it's honestly I I did it once nice it
was awesome and it doesn't irritate you
I mean that's the biggest thing is the
razor is so sharp that it doesn't make
you break out a normal review I do have
a fear during that procedure that
they're gonna slay your neck yeah
Sweeney Todd style just [ __ ] I ain't
you down I think I have a rational fear
that they'll just be like whoops got him
I was nervous it is it's freaky
I mean I got a guy with a razor sharp
utensil to your neck it's it's a little
uncomfortable but seems nice I like I
would go for that I like what this
article is on Yahoo style that's where I
calm you I love all these tech companies
trying to like exist in the shadow of
Google Yahoo style but the research
paper concludes that beards consistently
render men with an older more masculine
socially dominant and aggressive
appearance
oh damn girls are [ __ ] crazy I want a
man that's aggressive and dominant
beards may be more attractive to women
when considering long-term than short
term relation I'm looking
for a man that's socially dominant and
aggressive for a long-term relationship
as they indicate a male ability to sex
successfully compete socially with other
males for resources I think you're
looking way too much into this yeah I
think it's a fad of course not everyone
can grow a full beard it all depends if
it suits you okay whatever
tell me what else is Google style got to
tell me about the work yeah
do we have any clips of those crazy
preachers I was trying to find this Jim
Baker guy but can't seem to find any
evidence so Jim Baker if we've if we've
solid your name unfairly I apologize you
may or may not dig gaze now many people
think that whenever it's such a stupid
even many people think that you don't
think I should continue with the whole
preacher thing or no he's hidden the
board in the crickets many people think
you blame I say being gay is fine just
as long as you use Lube when you rub
your sticks together you can hit with
the cricket on that one bended Tom and
Christina we're at the thought of
cricket they were like so they were both
had this visitor like what yeah it's
funny to us because I I don't have that
problem there's so many I know it's
funny it's amazing to see they're both
really like recoil at the sound of the
cricket I love those guys they're so
freakin awesome aren't they yes they are
um what else we got here oh we got some
should we go on to fan submissions we're
at an hour 45 yeah it's time uh Joshua
McCarty says hi I'm a big fan of the
show and thought I would suggest showing
this gem of a video I'm from
Eastern Kentucky and my local news
station had a segment about a robbery I
won't say anymore but encourage you to
watch and enjoy Thank You Josh wolf I
think we're getting some really great
clips yeah I want to say guys keep
sending [ __ ] to podcasts @h straight
reproductions because there's been some
absolutely great stuff there I want
everything I want questions you want you
need advice you have any reaction any
suggestions for reaction videos you like
what you see
it all looks good that's what I was like
damn boy what you think you agreed that
it almost looks good well it what I mean
is that it looks like a style not not
the side you're showing us right now
[Laughter]
looks like you evacuated well it's just
not my style I'm not I'm not I'm not
slamming the style it's just not my
style
yeah that's all but I actually it was I
swear to God it felt so good to do it
all the way down it's really really
amazing it grows so fast it's already
like it was the skin two days ago
yeah oh I wonder if there's a research
about hair stubble research found that
men were more attractive when they
weren't completely bald to the skin Zach
just pointed out you actually look like
the dude from the dude from his Robert
De Niro from taxi driver yeah yeah we
wrote out a bunch of we had a bunch of
hair that was one of the insoles Maya we
had I looked like mr. cleans inbred
cousin and then how do you look like how
do you look like a Jew and a Nazi at the
same time yeah but that it was really
shaven and it looked like it when it was
in her
yeah we had a lot more you look like
definitely taxi driver reference at the
end there
God torturing people people are gonna be
demanding this video now it was really
bad anything folks the haircuts the best
part
you getting all the good memes what else
there were so many let me just I'm gonna
look like we got nothing to do we're at
the [ __ ] video no I'm gonna watch
that I just I want to at least enjoy
what little jokes
I want to salvage or whatever I can from
this more than what we said let's see
you look like a 90 villain extra yeah a
little bit those were all meant for me
to say to you look like a dollar store
zorg from Fifth Element um I think my
favorite is how do you look like a June
skin at the same time and mr. Queens
inbred cousins yeah that's great video I
just gave you the hi we can just clip
this and put this on me hopefully we are
going to start over and make a new video
new subjects new everything I hopefully
I can leverage this haircut into a new
joke I don't want to waste a broccoli
assassin cut for nothing I was calling
this the carrot cut because the broccoli
was more about the crown the carrot is
more about the stem oh yeah that's like
a carrot cut if I had spray tan I could
be a real carrot cut like a nice orange
you couldn't make that happen
alright let's watch this thank you too
for your submission Joshua your home is
never a good idea a Floyd County man
found that out for himself after having
a gun pointed at him when he did just
that wYMT Shawn Alan talked with the
victim in that case is on the rise
Methos
so his club must have been a bad batch
round here coz ford counties went crazy
in the last four days
neighbors notified Mason Tackett that
his cousin Philip Matthew Higgins was
seen carrying items from his house when
I finally got down here to the house
look see what happened the door was
standing wide open it looked like he was
packing up for yard sale when he came
back
by the way this shot okay get this shot
cracks me up what is he like 1 inch tall
yeah it's like a chase through grass
it's like like from his point of house
perspective an inch tall no it's not
that that's belonging to him around the
house because I guess he thought I was
upset with these items not normally the
target of a would-be burglar who steals
a cheese grater Philip Aegon's is
charged with receiving 7 million being a
convicted felon with a firearm in Turkey
Creek Shaun Allen wYMT Mountain News
hard to believe that's not a sketch yes
he stole my who steals a cheese grater
oh yeah where did you say Kentucky yeah
yeah Kentucky golly I feel like that
deserves a golly I feel like that
deserves a Jiminy Cricket I really you
could say anything with that accent and
it would be funny amazing
I'll tell you what no ok thank you see
hit me with that cricket you gotta like
I really don't mind it either can't use
it
golly Jiminy Cricket who steals a cheese
grater
he stole my Nana's I gotta find
something yo boo just boo
this was an interesting story Taylor
Swift apparently used to travel in a
suitcase to avoid paparazzi now Taylor
Swift was one of the most famous people
in the world and so I can understand
that trying to avoid paparazzi was
probably a source of great discomfort
and and annoyance to her to say that
leave but the the level that she went to
to avoid them was amazing and I want to
say as a testament to how annoying these
people are rather than that it should
reflect poorly on her that being said it
is incredible Zayn this was at One
Direction and Ian confirmed so this guy
from Zayn says Taylor Swift was travel
around in a suitcase during the summer
of 2007 teen and so he Isle of the huge
so here it is here's the alleged
suitcase now the other day explain to me
that this was actually a rumor at the
time and was like dismissed as just
being kind of a mean it's just way too
over-the-top to be real right but now
evidently this guy's saying no you know
this is all really happening Taylor
Swift so this guy they were dating or
they were friends and I feel super
famous yeah it's fine outing also it's
such like a undignified thing for
someone like Taylor Swift but alright
now curl up and I wonder if it's like
well-padded if it's nice and cooked I
was wondering that's what I like heard
of it or is it even like form cut to her
you know I mean like it's a little like
fetal position Taylor Swift slot that
she just like space in there Taylor
Swift being transported in a huge
suitcase from her Tribeca apartment into
her truck fleet of cars including
large Cadillacs and three SUVs arrived
at Taylor's apartment Rebecca dime of a
large suitcase from her apartment also
dozens of Taylor ship security guards
were present to move this package
carefully as Taylor Swift remains to be
unseen for a long time now I went and
there's a bunch of other photos of this
suitcase and for the audio listeners do
you understand this the suitcase is not
well you would have to be more than a
person for sure she'd have made her own
all crunched up in a ball like if you
build a cannonball into a swimming pool
so here some detectives have it's a
little bigger than a regular okay well
it looks like a mute for our use for
musical yeah but you can see here I mean
if anything this is kind of a testament
to how effed up this paparazzi imagine
you're willing to do crawl into a
frickin suitcase that well do you know
what she's probably doing she probably
wants to go do something private maybe
she wants to fly somewhere go to a beach
without everyone knowing what she's
doing all the time every day yeah so if
like I get it if you're trying to go
hang out with all these vultures like
filming you and recording you it's like
yeah
you know you got to do what you can I
always see videos of Justin Bieber and
the paparazzi people driving him crazy
yeah they're pretty aggressive with
Justin I've seen that [ __ ] till he gives
some [ __ ] back though I like watching
those yeah but there's a lot of videos
where he's nice at first and they really
push it well they yeah they start asking
him really inappropriate yeah like
getting in his way so he can't drive
away yeah yeah yeah man Fame on that
level is really yes so it can it's so
check people need to appreciate how
challenging and I mean those aspects for
sure I mean people are paid to try and
piss you off literally like they're just
there to piss you off so you flip out
and then it's a story story right just
imagine that everywhere you go in public
people are paid to piss you off and
record it yeah I mean so I hope that
people have a more of appreciation for
what ultra famous
we'll go through on a day-to-day basis
that it's not all just because there's I
always hear this kind of set of like oh
you have no right to complain it's like
tell that to somebody that crawls into
the side a suitcase I mean obviously the
the riches and the fame that that is
nice and I'm sure they enjoy that but
you're right it comes with baggage comes
with some serious baggage to a lot a lot
money doesn't buy you happiness I
guarantee and promise you that it buys
you well one way ticket in a freaking
suitcase in this case I thought that was
wild I was frankly shocked by that yeah
what else we got what else we got
what the Frick gals do we got people
showing explosion but that little Kanye
goof Ian do you have anything to say
about this Kanye goes oh you want to
come in here and watch it with us he's
like Jay King said please no really
there's not much to watch sweet guy you
know but if you don't want to I won't
force you I mean I understand that you
have a choice I'm not gonna podcast rape
you uh-huh but you are fired if you
don't come with should we show it now
yellow let me find it there's a new meme
now about what else me saying what else
there is
yep used to be fascinating now it's what
else that's funny
it's been a long a one-pot okay where is
it I got a whole list of things here
what else do you see in this document
yeah I'm looking at it right now
you can you highlight it for me yep when
I see it there it is okay
Kanye has gone on stage dressed as the
Joker correct me if I'm wrong
not intentionally I hate to say this and
I don't want to offend anybody but he
kind of looks like the guy that I hate
to say this so don't say we shouldn't
the hair color and the Joker is
reminiscent of okay I'm not oh and the
guy that shot up the theater on the
Batman not saying he's shooter are just
saying it looks like the guy is that
awful to say I mean he looks like he's
doing the Elaine dance kind of from
people have speculated that he's on
drugs is that substantiate er you think
he's just having fun I think once the
power of that music just takes over your
soul you can't do much but just let it
possess you like that's the drug yeah
it's the beauty of his music mm-hmm
thank you very much reminds me of Elaine
though and a little bit of a goober just
in general like fun what am I talking
about why were you such an [ __ ] he's
having a good time let it go dude dance
like nobody's watching that's what they
say whatever gotta judge the guy ruin a
good ass time why people gotta say it
looks like the shooter who shot up
Batman
theater yeah who's saying that [ __ ]
ignorant he's having a great time yeah I
wish I could go out public and dance
like that
get it I heard that people were really
happy with his performance in a good
time dude look at me being it yeah yeah
let's see what they think somebody's go
yeah whatever I mean to recover imagine
reading reddit comments on live on a
podcast well it's been less the wedding
dress is very short so let's wrap it up
here Texas woman declares our protective
woman celebrates our divorced by blowing
up her wedding dress well I can see that
that was a healthy relationship man what
the hell did that guy do to you
there's like a whole party here to
celebrate that was a lot more than I
expected yeah just be like a little m80
or something that's a real explosion
what that guy did to her man but that's
a good it's a good thing you guys got
the board
yeah all right guys we're thinking of
doing an extra episode on Tuesday now me
being a fan of the Howard Stern Show
they have this segment called cleaning
out the computer which is all the
segments and all the stuff they had
planned that they never got time to do
on the show thinking of setting up a
panel here with Ian and Dan to join us
and to go over all the great things of
the year that we never had time to get
to do an extra episode on Tuesday let me
know what you guys think about that idea
not that well who watches this deep
anyway if you if you're watching type in
the comments
what should they type in the comments
under the Frog loves Miss Piggy's big
titties right yeah that's the classroom
that was the big one but I want to know
did you know that I read this that farts
used to be actually a danger to public
safety before people started wearing
underwear because you would actually
fart out Air Assault [ __ ] particles
people could breathe them and get sick I
swear that's why I read that's why
people wear underwear they invented it
back in the day so I read it I don't
remember but it seems credible but that
your farts obviously our permit are
passed through the fabric so the [ __ ]
particles are not allowed to freely
enter your neighbor's face so you look
that up I swear that going commando is
like a public health nuisance well no I
think through the pants you're probably
fine but if you're like bare ass farting
I don't know look it up I swear fact
check me right now you know I am he was
all [ __ ] I think that whole that
whole statement about farts being
dangerous that's what people should type
if they've stuck around this deep hmm
type this did you know farts are
dangerous if you're not wearing
underwear done deal and then if I see
that I'll know that you want an episode
on Tuesday well if you watch this tape
you probably do want to Epsilon - this
isn't a good sample size necessarily
listen this guys have a blessed
beautiful Friday thank you all so much
for watching and again I want to thank
you guys too for all the nice comments
the episode before last was
and other than amazing yeah no I mean
there's been a lot of criticism which
I'm happy that I've acknowledged but
there's also been a lot of love and
support and understanding which I have a
tendency to focus on the negative and
dismiss the positive but that's so
messed up and everybody who takes their
time to show support and love it means
so it's so important to me it's so
appreciated yeah thank you
I mean truly so with that being said oh
I didn't mean to do that one I'm sorry
you guys nobody loves that one yeah I
meant to do that well I'm not going to
touch the sound
thank you all have a blessed beautiful
Friday a wonderful productive happy
wholesome weekend there's a good chance
we might be her on Tuesday
bite and Friday and then the week after
bill Wirtz which I'm very good also was
there any progress on getting uh what
was his name
what was his name that comedian I love
I'm blanking you were in touch with them
oh yeah I've got Ryan Ryan Ryan Ryan
Brian Regan Brian Regan there you go I
love him so much so he might be coming
home there's no plan we are also
planning to do a charity stream like
last year yes and that might be the last
episode of this year right that's on
what the heck was that
cheering no we've officially run out the
outro song it's looping oh [ __ ] we got
plenty time to talk about yeah we'll
have time to talk about it that was
gonna be on December well hey thanks for
watching guys we love you wish you all
the cake on Tuesday bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]